oh yeah yeah come on for those of you
who
all right we're going so anyway so our
net speaker on Circus okay thank you
very much for inviting me for this nice
workshop and so my name is Hong Seok
young again but I'm going to talk about
in the next about 30 or 40 minutes is my
joint work with Rafa units and UOIT and
means this is more about the inference
problem of probability programming
language and actually my background is
programming languages so what I'm I
guess the way you can understand or
approach my talk is this non expert in
probability and the inference car
influenced area try to explain some
influence to perhaps some of the expert
so I hope if I make some mistake
you understand what I'm kind of correct
me and also if you are like me you don't
understand anything about this area I
mean it's okay to stop me and ask
questions okay so I mean I have a I walk
we closely work with some of my friend
in Oxford like Frank Oh than uit and
they are from the machine learning
machine learning background and they're
quite interested in probability
programming but when I ask them about
what's the main challenge for progress
programming they all say impressed so
they really want to have a very
efficient inference algorithm and it
turns out coming up with efficient
inference algorithm for probability
programming is actually quite hard I
mean though there are a few many reasons
about this and one reason is these
inference algorithm has to be generic it
has to in some people call it Universal
it has to work on all kinds of program
that's written in the probability
programming language and what does that
mean is did some of these algorithms
like a particular variation and
inference algorithm which are quite
efficient they cannot be used because
they kind of assume the either like
model is finite right you can be
represented as a finite graph or
sometimes it assumed that some of these
particular component of your program you
know how to compute something with
integration so as you can how to compute
the expectation and so on so most of the
language not all but quite a lot of
languages are based on Monte Carlo
simulations because I mean there
in France algorithms are based on Monte
Carlo simulation that's because Monte
Carlo simulation assumes very little if
you can execute program or so that you
can generate samples or so you can score
sample by score I mean computes
potentially on normalize density for the
sample then these algorithm works and
produce some nice Aiken sample if it
works under meanwhile in the machine
learning community I mean they according
to what I hear from my friends they also
recognize this period designing
variational inference are going to be
very hard so they came up with the
so-called black box variational
inference techniques so the key idea of
these technique is there are some tricky
part of designing variational inference
algorithm you replace it by some kind of
Monte Carlo simulation so in some sense
it makes some idea of Monte Carlo
simulation also it makes some idea of
variational inference such a way that in
some sense the user of this technology
or this type of infant generated
inference I will deny kind of a universe
that can be applied to why the class or
program so in fact this kind of main
universality is noticed by existing
machine learning researchers and they
applied it to probability program so for
instance I mean I think weighing Kate
Weber first came up with this how to do
variation an inference will probably
SPRO gram for particular applications
crook I mean this group of people and
then also some group of people in Oxford
they applied variational inference
techniques to be in the in this group of
people's case they are put a train topic
model for about 200 or 300 thousand
lines of 200 thousand documents which is
quite a big oppa Chipman for applying
probability programming language and in
the case of jung eum's
this second group may they apply this
use this variational inference
techniques to use probabilistic
programming for policy search so but I
kind of I and you I started is maybe
this is in some sense they took what
machine learning people have done and
they have just applied it to the
probability program but maybe if we
started a little bit further maybe we
can find some what Big Dipper synergy
so maybe these are women can be
specialized and exploit some of the uses
in structures about propolis program in
something that's the kind of research
direction I'm working on and if I
overtime at the end I would take talk a
little bit about I mean about this a
little bit so my talk has our two
objective I mean in England's like every
lecturer when they started it they
learnt some form of course on teaching
and the one thing they learn about
teaching is that you always have to
clarify so-called learning objective in
the beginning of your lecture so I have
a two objective in my lecture why am i
talk the objective one is just
understand what black box variation
influenced means in particular in the
context of probability program so if you
understand this I'll be really happy and
then say my talk is successful but the
second part I at the end if I for some
time I will explain some of the
preliminary research that I'm getting I
mean this one is all about approximate
inference so the best way to judge it to
have some experiments but I don't have
implementation I don't have a experiment
so in some sense I don't really know
whether these ideas are working or not
but anyhow I thought some of the
findings are interesting so at the end
if I have time I would mention a bit a
little bit about this so let me give us
some other review of a probability
program because I want everybody is on
the same page and also I wanted to have
some operational reading about
probability program so here I chose some
very kind of contrived example which is
good many good folder my talk okay but
don't pay kind of too much meaning about
put too much meaning on this example so
what this example does is that it take
some sample from beta distribution if
you don't know anything about beta
distribution we can just I mean this we
can just say this is a distribution
which we term vary between zero and one
so you can use it as a probability when
you flip a coin
so X randomly initialized to value
between 0 and 1 and then we flip a coin
based on the sample the value of X and
if we coin flip turn out to be true then
we sample something from the sample Y
from the normal distributions where the
mean of the normal distribution has is a
strange value
here if the coin flip is a force we are
again sample from the normal
distribution but mean is changed
something different at the end we say we
made on observations that observation is
this is to me this last line is
essentially say we observed Y modulus of
noise small noise and observed period
wise was equal to 3 that's the reading
of the program that's one way to
understand this program is by actually
running it so let's run think about a
particular execution so let's say all
the variables are means in this
execution I have a two variable x and y
so these accent why I've initialized to
zero and in this particular execution
model or you can say to an operational
semantics I have an additional variable
called W that track so some people the
Croesus a likelihood try likely score by
each track you can think of it as a
weight while if you are familiar with
important sampling this W really record
the weights in the important sampling
now let's run this program so we first
execute simple and then we sample the
value was 0.8 so then X gets the bet X
becomes 0.28 now we flip a coin then how
come of the coin flip turn out to be
true then we go to the true branch and
I'm from true branch we use X square
which is 0.6 for as a mean value and
sample sample from normal distribution
where zero point six point six four is a
mean value the outcome of 0.3 that's
stored in variable Y and that become the
majority of the intercepting else and at
the end we evaluate this normal so
there's no more defined probability
density with the probability density for
normal distribution whose mean is 0.23
and standard deviation is 1 if you
evaluate this PDF with value 3 then
that's going to be a 0.01 something
which roughly means I mean this 0.23 is
a quite different from the observed
value 3 so that's why your score is very
low but this is a one execution outcome
of this execution so this is one way to
understand probability program operation
on the it's
just generate sample it together also it
creates some weight alongside and now
once we have this example then we can do
two things in probability program so
this if you just ignore this weight then
this there it is trace the execution
trace to make that sequence of a state
you are painting is actually a sample
from the prior distributions that you
are getting from this program for the
more in the presence of probability
program you can actually compute prior
density how you do it for you can see
that which random choices are made
during this execution that was first
beta flip and normal distribution the
true branch and then you also know which
values are sampled at the moments just
use it and apply this probability
approach appropriate probability density
in those three places they will allow
you to compute this probability density
for this trace sorry so what my to sum
up what I say is we you can gather a
sample from the prior also you can
compute probability density of this
prior trace okay this means am this
example now also this weight directly
correspond to this likelihood score it
means coming from this observation and
this kind of property holds for only all
the execution so there are some other
executions where the first sample was
0.6 and it happens that equals the first
branch we get different value this time
like little like loose corrigible
higher because 3.5 you are a lot closer
to 3 then 0 point something that we saw
before so then the in this case we again
get our sample from the prior as well as
we are able to calculate this prior
density and then there is also
likelihood score so so operationally 1/8
understand probability program is this
generation of the sample to get way to
the sample and so that's an operational
semantics but it's not in some sense of
what we really want to describe using
this propolis program what we want to
describe is a posterior and then there
is a standard way to if you have a way
to
generate is weighted a sample from the
prior then there is a standard way to
generate distributions on the posterior
distribution by a so-called important
sampling yes stupid question
how do you get point 35 you say I have
at this point the value of y is a 3.5 so
then I can compute probability density
of normal distribution mean 3.5 and
various standard deviation 1 then I plug
in value 3 that will give us zero point
three five let's multiply to one yes
right density of the observed data and
it should I think of it as some likely
it is to be observing free in this
possible trace how that's right I mean
this particular to how well it matches
with observation so it's like a Skype is
high I'm doing very good if it's low
then I mean this trace is crap now if
you do it and there is actually this
idea of importance simply can be
understood as a standard way of
converting this outcome of this
operational semantics meaning idea word
you can generate infinitely many samples
you can convert these infinitely many
samples into the distribution so here's
a way to do this I describe it finite
way but if you send this finite number
and to the infinity you get the
distribution so what what you do is you
if you keep running the original program
you get way to the sample you have a
trace together with weights and so on so
you have n way to the samples then the
way to generate distribution is really
simple you just define the discrete
distribution on how taught me where
which have a probability mass on tau 1
tau 2 up to tau n but then now you have
to assign probability for each other how
I tower these probabilities assigned in
proportion to these weights so that's
what this formula is saying then you can
act I think maybe there knows a lot
better than I do
so if you send and to the infinity I
think this converge to this
distribution inappropriate sense she
means like if you want to compute
expectations using these samples and
then using this actual posterior
distribution will give the exactly same
user T right so this is a semantic
operational semantics this a way to
understand their what how this
operational semantics generate posterior
distribution now the question is if you
just do the important assembling
sometimes it works really well but not
always I mean you can kind of see why it
doesn't work I mean when I generate
samples it doesn't have no idea about
data at all it just generates sample
according to the in some sense trip
which is written in my program yes so it
seems to me that in nominal programming
a Bayesian inference you not actually
finished sorry me refresh sorry so here
you your the asymptotic result of your
probe listing experiments is a
probability on all possible traces of
your code then you can project it to the
if you're only interested in the output
state you can project it to the output
state as well no no okay but that's not
what I'm interested in I'm interested in
going the other way and exploiting this
to update my prior so how do this so
this I mean these samples the infinite
amount of sample is in some sense a
description of this posterior
distribution but it's on traces right
it's not on the actual parameters of my
code so here prior ASAP is also
described on the traces so then
everything is under this you can maybe
look lemon there's a continuous function
ostensibly from the trace to whatever
print parameter value you're interested
in and so by weak convergence theory
you'll also get convergence in the law
of that particular summary so this will
induce a posterior on every parameter
you might be interested in
there was my question okay thank you
this one button means quite often it
doesn't work because when you generate
trace trace it has no idea about the
object data so it's instance a very
unguided way of generating samples so
the many of this idea of what it
inference algorithm in probabilistic
programs design instances took
incorporate this information about the
data and then structure of the program
and somehow to a little bit more clever
a club or much more clever way to
january samples so and then black box
variation our inference is also another
way to the incorporated idea and the
that's what I'm going to explain now so
then the idea of a variational inference
I mean it's already explained in one of
the talks in the after window in the
morning it's quite simple so you want to
but like watch my objective my objective
is I want to describe posterior
distribution but it's really hard so
what should I do
so then one approach is you choose
family of simple distributions which you
know you can deal with really well you
can generate samples nice samples really
well
well maybe you can compute integration
very well so you have a very simple
collection of this family of
distribution then you change posterior
inference problem as an optimization
problem you say what I want to do is I
want to find one of the distribution one
of the theta which in some sense closes
to the posterior distribution as much as
possible according to this notion of a
KL divergence I'm going to explain what
this K divergence means later roughly
speaking it measures how to distribution
the similar so bottoms but this one you
are saying is I want to find closest
distribution in this approximating
family what this is done and then if
somebody asks me questions about
posterior I'm not gonna use posterior at
all I mean
this approximating taker my
approximating distribution and then
answer all those questions this is a
kind of general scheme of the variation
in France according to what I hear it's
called variation in France because it's
of optimization on something like a
function like object now the question
becomes then Hartman the main part of
the variation I the influence becomes
this part too I mean if you know how to
solve this number two then I mean you
can actually that's the core idea of
their various variation inference
algorithms and typically I mean one of
the typical approach is doing message
passing and then you can kind of say I'm
acting you can kind of imagine what it
would look like you want to optimize
this particular objective function what
are you going to do when you just say
it's a derivative is equal to zero and
you want to find an extremal point if
you work out what this equation actually
looked like sometimes you end up with
the so called some kind of fixed point
equation that can be understood as a
pessimist keep passing algorithm so
that's a one way to do it
or maybe for some simple models this
derivative equal to zero can also be
directly approached from for some
different means black box variation is
required some understanding about how to
deal with this formula symbolically so
black box variational inference I take a
different approach which is you try to
solve this problem directly by gradient
descent so say this some modified
version of a K diverges it take it as an
objective function and you say okay what
I want to do is I want to minimize that
objective function and then double
easiest way is between here crime here
kind of not climbing but going down a so
it does this kind of things based on
this gradient now another key idea of
black box variation and inference is now
this means I have should be able to
compute gradients and sometimes the
computing gradient itself is a heart so
you use Monte Carlo estimate of the
gradient so these are the two idea use a
gradient descent
second idea is use Monte Carlo estimates
of the gradient
let's kind of work out a little bit on K
divergence so here's a definition of ka
divergence the K divergence is a
symmetric way of comparing to
distribution and what they say is it
compared the so these two guys are
probability density function on traces
you compare these two density functions
they take their ratio if they are the
same the ratio will be 1 so if you take
a look a rhythm then it's going to be
barely have value 0 if taka is really
high this value will have a value larger
than 1 so this logarithm will gave a
positive value and so on so do you take
a ratio and then you'll take the average
of this ratio so that's what ka
divergence si and and the reason why is
it's good to think about this
optimization problem is sometimes if you
walk on an optimization problem you can
manipulate you can get rid of lots of a
constant in your optimal objective
function that's the case in that also
happens in this case so now I unpack
this definition my posterior is the same
as prior time the likelihood divided by
some normalization constant so this is
instance of the Bayes rule
now the problem usually typical quantity
to calculate is this normalization
constant so if somebody asked me to
calculate this this is a really hard
problem but it happens that this jet is
a normalization constant which has
nothing to do with the theta and then
because of the property of logarithm I
can take it out as a separate sum and
this one has nothing to do with the
theta I can get rid of it in my
objective function so this K a
divergence I mean one good thing about
it is that because I'm solving
optimization problem I can play with my
objective function without really
changing the solution so if I play a
little bit then I can get either very
deep quantity which is very hard to hard
to find so then this becomes my new
objective function where now my
comparison is between
approximating distributions and then
sometimes this is called joint density
like prior density times likelihood
school
okay so this is a simplification I do
the second key observation of black box
variation and process now we want to
compute optimize or minimize this
function by using gradients then there
should be a way to compute the mean
estimate well fine
should be a way to calculate this
gradient it happens that if you compute
these gradients then you can actually
switch in some sense this gradient
operator and expectation operator I mean
so some my friend told me that mean for
him whenever he look at this expectation
operator he always immediately imagine
an arboretum because expectation
operator one way to read it is getting a
sample from this distribution and then
from the sample you calculate the
quantity on the right hand side and take
an average that give you a way to
estimate this this quantity so if you
somehow manipulate a formula such a way
that expectation goes outside they give
a Monte Carlo estimation algorithm of
the quantity that you care about so
that's what you can get and another
important point is what I again heard
from my friend is if you try to compute
gradient of estimation that's really bad
but if you try to compute estimation of
gradients then becomes a lot better
still it has a high variance but it
works a lot better so this is a simple
mathematical truth and metric my
equations which is true but this allows
you to kind of get what much more
efficient well the algorithm which are
the less barriers
just a question so you're taking
expectations with respect to Q which
isn't the one I mean you'd naturally
want to take expectations with respect
to P right so you say something about
how so safe you so I think that people
do it because they simplify the mess but
if you do it the other way around it's
really hard because that means I need to
so what was nice about this is I can
easily generate sample from this
approximating distribution that's why
this formula is nice but if you swap
them I need to generate sample from
posterior which is a hard problem so
what people do is that I mean they have
to use some different techniques and I
mean it's something that I'm discussing
with the ey is we are thinking about
using some super cross entropy method
and so we if they have a expectation
with respect to the original
distributions then that's very hard to
generate but what we can do is you kind
of come up with a proposal distribution
which which is good enough to make some
little bit of progress and you keep
applying of changing your proposal
description again and again so there's a
process entropy method maybe you know
this so then we are thinking about how
applied to I mean for the other
situation we are thinking about apply
this cross entropy method together
another approximate algorithm
right so this is I mean just we kept up
but I just said now this is a formula
gradient formula that I just showed you
in the previous slide how he converted
to an algorithm there is really simple
you initialize a theta to some initial
value theta is usually some vector of
real numbers you just initialize to zero
or something and then you keep applying
this again and again until theta doesn't
change and then what you do is that you
sample bunch of the traces up from the
approximating distributions and based on
the sample you estimate this quantity
and then use that quantity to update
your theta so essentially you do a hill
climbing and this one has I mean there
are all sorts of techniques which
improve this kind of simple algorithm
but I mean this is the base algorithm
let me show you how this works for
probabilistic program how much time I
have so I'm show you how it works for
probabilistic program so this is a
program that you see in the beginning of
my talk now how you obtain the exact
approximating family it's really easy
what you can do is you first get rid of
observations so this observation party
is gone in my approximating family
because I want some of my approximation
here's one easy way to generate sample
from my approximation then the second
thing I do is whenever I have a
distribution essentially maintain the
structure of the program but I just
remove the parameters of all the
distributions that I used in my program
so a Peter instead of using three and
two I use just a theta 1 and theta 2
flip instead of a using x iu 2 theta 3
and so on and then my question becomes
can I somehow find the appropriate value
of theta 1 up to theta 5 such a way that
this program if I could just running it
it generates sample which is very close
to posterior distribution
you know because you're you are you're
killing all the the control dependencies
in the executioner so here that main
trick is if I fixed particular theta 1
up to theta 5 it's completely crazy but
if I'm allowed to choose right theta 1
up to theta 5 becomes a lot nicer you
are exactly right this is a crazy
approximation but good part of this so
some people say I mean when Yun Willam
applied this idea he doesn't really kill
everything he killed him maintained some
part of this and killed only some subset
but I just chose this as an illustration
theta 1 theta fiber some particular
numbers they are not from distributions
there are numbers which is second domain
of the optimization so now how it works
so initially you can say the pair D
theta 1 theta 2 a1 when this value is
0.5 there for normal life the value was
a 0 then we run this program then they
give this trace and from this particular
trace what we can do is we can use this
trace because these two programs have
exactly the same control structure I can
imagine this this trace actually when we
interpret this trace as a trace of the
original program that allowed me to
compute the it is join density returns
density for the prior as well as
likelihood score and also by looking at
my approximating program I can compute
the quantity the the density of this
tracer with respect to approximating
program as well as this derivative and
using that view I can update chi and
using this company compute estimates
estimation of the gradient and using it
to update my theta so so I put some
arbitrary barrier to show that something
happens I think you're superimposing to
play different things
like one is the abstract operation of
putting all your details and having this
isomorphism between traces and
completing some kind of metric between
the two induced probability
distributions on the one hand which is
you know and abstract enough Michael
Fang which she just explained very well
and the the the the top right little box
which is how you can actually compute a
good Tita which is going to minimize the
scale or whatever metric you find and
this is a completely different question
it's an important question obviously I
thought it maybe we can talk later yeah
thanks yeah I'm not objecting to were
just applying this potato barrier play
pass variation in France it's developed
for arbitrary model and then here I'm
just instantiate in for so choosing this
particular approximation is arbitrary
choice there has to be some needs to be
some care about to make sure certain
properties are true but this is
arbitrary choice than what I done is
also arbitrary kind of decision so
approximation for program is is some
separate work right so then in the
picture
so then what happen is from TV I just
generate samples and then a computer
score I mean they're based on the square
comes with a gradient and then you do
the gradient descent I think maybe I
have one or two minutes worth noting
yeah
so for one over two minutes I'm gonna
tell you a little bit about what I've
done
so it turns out if you mean this
probabilistic program actually a Markov
chain the probabilistic program of my
approximating program is a Markov chain
which means probability density it can
be decomposed as density for each step
so then if you exploit a structure
actually this K divergence ahead or some
different form you can see and what the
way I put it is if just means we are
doing lots of integrations mean in
analytically so in the big
is roughly speaking a lot less
integration if you do this menu it turns
out it's this formula can be expressed
an equivalent formula that does a lot
more integration and then if I I can
follow exactly the same strategy take
about different algorithm I just show
you the picture that algorithm works in
the beginning part it's the same you get
a straight generate traces from the
approximating program but the quantity
you are computing is not about like this
step that you are taking so this use
this trace headers in some sample of
whichever state and for those of each
other state you are considering all the
possible next state and then do some
point of integration there and then
allow you to compute a different way of
estimating this data the gradient as I
said I don't have an implementation so I
don't know whether it works well or not
but I've my hobbyist because I do a
little bit more work in math I hope pigs
give a better algorithm and something
similar happens if we do a little bit
better then there are different
algorithm and that's the only thing I
mean that's the whole thing I want to
say okay so thank you very much two
questions
sir so the would black box suggests I
can take any paralytic program right I
think the part I don't understand how I
generate the variational summation so
that part I think they I agree with you
that so then simple optimization like
removing observation is easy and then
now which part will be placed at ease
that that requires another research so
simple of heuristic is if I can do it I
replaced because these are real value
parameters then just wait for the rest
if I can't do it just a little bit there
there's also formal approximating firm
whether it's going to give us something
good or not I don't know but what the
maybe or maybe not
oh yeah but the Anil update is he just
replaced one or two random to remove old
observation but remove one or two random
choices in the beginning and that
allowed them to calculate the right
quantity so I mean the kind of policy
that they are looking for but it's a
it's a problem and I mean as I said in
the beginning my background is
programming languages I hope that some
idea of program analysis can be used to
find out that away or some identify more
opportunities of these optimization I
mean these are approximating family and
for me that more troubling thing is this
black box variational inference this
type of let variation an inference the
support of approximating distribution
should be a subset and many very
verification will program analyst
techniques often if you approximated you
did support become a superset so that's
what bothers me a lot more so that's why
we are I mean I Anu I are talking about
this mean cross entropy based other
approximation technique
any more questions
I guess I would agree with well I'm not
sure if its agreement Stuart but to
follow Stewart's point I think the
problem of defining and interesting
variational families and ones that
aren't so closely tied to the recent tax
to the original problem is a very
difficult one and it's not it's not
really clear that's a mathematical one
might be a language design one how do
you give people tools so they can
describe variational approximation
families and that not be a massive
amount of work for them and also
something that composes appropriately if
you take two programs you'd like to
paint on the hard work of building
variational automation and you'd like it
not impossible to combine those
variational approximations and so on
right I have a question you know about
the relationship between you two talks
you are defining some kind of random
walk on the space of traces to sample
from the good posterior right is that
does that connect in a way you can view
MCMC as a as a sequential Monte Carlo
algorithm in a much higher dimensional
space and it will produce weights just
like concept was using I'm not aware of
how that plays with variational
inference I mean your method looks like
it's done some in a way that respects
maybe it's also closer to what you are
programming is at the beginning it's
more respectful of the program structure
and your is more like from the outside
so maybe it's a I mean if if your
methodology works maybe it's just your
short cutting so you practice I my
experience is I mean this but then
described in Anglican school library
better policing it works really well
I mean lock works I thought it's not
very smart algorithm but somehow
surprisingly well many examples
with your last little question so is
there with this somewhere the idea that
you could remember some stuff and not
redo or something all the time so at the
moment I mean cuz if I do the
implementation
I think I would have to think about some
memorization and what I heard for like a
TENS but the kind of algorithm then
presented even you restart to remember
or later be more you can save lots of
computation because it has a lot of
competitions get repeated but then we
have to find the right balance between
the tracking extra informations and
avoiding some you repeat to the
computation that turned out to be
sometimes quite hard especially if you
try to compile it so the Anglican
compiles program into Java Virtual
Machine and then run does that kind of
standard a closure or runtime system and
if you start to pedal with it and you
slow down dramatically thank you very
much